[Musique]
la poste de la rue d'ulm arrondissement
il est 17h j'envoie un pneumatique rue
cognacq-jay
[Musique]
non
je vous dois
[Musique]
dans combien de temps il va t'il environ
une heure
[Musique]
cette lettre nous allons maintenant la
suivre tout au long des 15 km de
parcours qui vont l'amener à la poste de
la rue cler première étape la gare de
l'est à un aiguillage automatique va
orienter notre team
[Applaudissements]
ce tube qui possède une aspérité un
grand qui déclenche électriquement
l'aiguillage
direction la bourse
le centre vital il y as entend
exactement il y naquit le réseau en 1866
3 km 400 km en 1966 400 km de tube
souterrain qui quadrillent la capitale
huit millions de missives transportés
chaque année
[Musique]
la bourse est un centre de prise chaque
jour des milliers de lettres passe de
marne
le flux qui porte l'étude c'est l'air
pulsé comprimé raréfier le voici dans
l'atelier de force motrice il y en a
sept dans tout paris ici trois machines
265 chevaux chacune pulse l'air sans
arêtes vers les 15 centres de force qui
le distribue aux quatre coins de la
capitale
si le curseur ce bloc banking et
l'accident est peu fréquent on envoie
une colonne d'air et en fonction du
temps de compression et de détente
on peut localiser à 10 mètres près le
tube obstrué 17h35 notre message se
glisse dans l'entrelacement il réel de
cette forêt super m de tubes et de
tuyaux le central 103 rue de grenelle
point de correspondance la lettre
changera de tubes et repart vers le
poste de la rue cler paris 7 sept
17 à 45 le message arrive
un quart d'heure plus tard le petit
télégraphiste déposera
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]